bâti au but marqué une victoire au bout
du suspense de maurepas face à plaisir
pourtant tout avait mal commencé pour
les verts dans cette demi finale de
coupe des yvelines avec cette ouverture
du score des plaisirs oit sur leur
terrain juste avant la mi-temps on a
joué à la baballe on joue à deux à
l'heure sans intensité
au final on se fait contrer c'était sûr
que ça allait se passer comme ça et on
prend notre but comme ça donc on a fait
le taf
une occasion un but il faudra faire une
meilleure deuxième mi temps je pense au
retour des vestiaires les contre
attaques s'enchaînent pour plaisir après
un premier avertissement avec ce tir sur
le poteau
les attaquants arrivent à combiner pour
faire le break 2 à 0 mal en point les
mots repasser un réagissent dans la
foulée sur coup franc avant d'égaliser
dans les dernières secondes pour
arracher la séance de tirs au but
c'est super dur sata un coup au moral on
se dit 2 0 il reste même pas de trois
minutes ont cependant un 2-2 par l'ensam
un coup au moral mais voilà prenons mais
on essaye d'être comme andy
professionnels et garder la tête haute
finalement plaisir à deux penalties
s'incline 4 tirs au but à 3 maurepas
jouera la finale de la coupe d i mean
pour la deuxième fois en trois ans
scénario du match fait qu'il ya encore
plus de bonheur égalisa dernières
secondes après les tirs au but ce jour
la loterie un peu mais ça fait trois
fois qu'on passe aux tirs au but donc on
peut dire qu'on est assez à l'aise dans
l'exercice finalement dans l'autre
demi-finale du haut cours s'est imposé 5
à 1 face à hardricourt et deux équipes
de d1 de district se rencontre on le 3
juin prochain à maisons laffitte